[Music]
on this Saturday night tanks deep inside
the Gaza Strip as Israel's ground war
begins the intensified retaliation and
the second phase over that deadly Hamas
attack to the residents of Northern Gaza
and Gaza City your window to act is
closing the casualties as Israel's
Defense Force steps up its assault
unbearable anxiety I can't wait anymore
I need my son M families of hundreds of
hostages held captive demand answers
from Israel's leader fears the military
Onslaught puts loved ones at
risk plus condemnation in Canada we're
really outrageous we're fed up we know
that we're complicit in this the
frustration over
inaction global national with baren
Asser good evening Israel has shifted to
the second phase in the war and is
pounding Gaza with its full Firepower
after expanding its ground operation
inside the Palestinian
[Applause]
territory overnight Israel's Defense
Force intensified its bombing campaign
on a scale civilians inside Gaza have
never seen before tanks also moving
deeper inside Gaza backed up by that
constant barrage of air strikes fired
from the ground and from the
sea the war will be long and difficult
stressed Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu in a televised news conference
tonight a rare and lengthy broadcast
message to the world in which he took
questions from journalists for the first
time since the outbreak of the
conflict the comments made while Mass
Carnage unravels within Gaza just how
much we don't know because internet and
lines of communication are cut off after
key infrastructure was wiped out AIDS
still very slow to reach those in need
and a warning some of the details and
images in our coverage tonight might be
disturbing to some of our viewers our
Danielle hjin has our top story from
Jerusalem tonight Danielle strong words
from Netanyahu what more did he have to
say far off for years Benjamin Netanyahu
positioned himself as Mr security but
today he refused to take any
responsibility for the intelligence
failures that led to the October 7th
attacks he believes his mission now is
to save the country calling it Israel's
second war of independence he said never
again and never again he added begins
today we can't see the gunfire but we
can hear
it Israel says its troops are still in
Gaza after an overnight expansion of its
operations
after what the UN says was the most
intensive bombardment yet on The
Enclave the Israeli Defense Forces claim
to have struck 150 targets and to have
killed a number of Hamas commanders
among them a key figure in the planning
of the deadliest attack on Jews since
the
Holocaust today officials in Tel Aviv
once again issued an urgent call for
Palestinians to evacuate to the South of
Gaza Hamas puts your life in danger by
placing weapons and forces within
civilians area in Gaza including schools
masks and
hospitals with a near Total Blackout
getting any information out of the
territory is practically
impossible recorded on Friday before
communication lines went down these are
some of the last images to come out of
shifa Hospital located in the North and
specifically mentioned by
Israel thousands are seeking Refuge here
while the children are just trying to be
children the babies in the neonatal unit
are at the mercy of Staff who refuse to
evacuate Israel says that beneath them
underground is a Hamas Command Center
Global News cannot verify that
claim I am in you she says please stop
this Bloodshed now we can't bear it
anymore enough is enough people
definitely um we're took were taken away
by surprise we were able to speak
briefly with Mansour Shuman of Calgary
as he huddled next to local journalists
for a signal all my feelings are being
now suppressed and channeled into action
all I'm focused on is getting the
message out to the world in eng English
uh about what's happening here to the
Palestinian people by seeing an
escalation in the diseases given the
crowded spaces and the lack of cleaning
supplies 70 kilometers away from Gaza is
Tel
Aviv where normal life is interrupted by
air rate Sirens Hamas continues to
strike the bombing campaign in Gaza many
say is absolutely Justified we m do it
because we have no other choice I mean
if we won't do it they will destroy us
and in response to claims made by the
Turkish leader that Israel could be
guilty of war crimes Netanyahu defended
the IDF saying it does everything to
avoid harming
non-combatants he also pulled his
diplomats out of turkey far Danielle
Haman in Jerusalem tonight thank you
Danielle as Israel intensifies its
attacks on Gaza fears are mounting for
the hundreds of hostages held captive by
Hamas prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
today met with representatives of the
hostages families where he promised to
do everything possible to bring them
back now that was not before those
families rallied in Tel Aviv today
demanding more assurances on the safety
of their loved ones as Israel's military
operation
escalates no I can't wait anymore I need
my son back home and I need the mission
was happened in the prime minister in
the also the defense minister on their
shift they have to solve Sol it now
joining me now is Global News
investigative journalist St Bell who was
there in Tel Aviv he now joins us from
Jerusalem St what was the mood like uh
from those people today and and what's
their position on how they can get their
loved ones
back well hundreds of Israelis have been
Gathering today in Tel Aviv and they
want to make sure that the prison
prisoners held hostage by Hamas since
October the 7th aren't forgotten and the
concern of course is that the Israeli
military has now moved its land
operation into Gaza without the prisoner
issue being resolved uh we still have
roughly 230 Israeli and other Nationals
that are still held captive and uh their
slogan today was everyone for everyone
they're proposing a deal in which Hamas
release all of the prisoners and in
exchange Israel will release all of uh
the h us prisoners in its
custody what is prime minister Netanyahu
saying about
that uh prime minister Netanyahu uh he
said that all the freeing all of the
prisoners was one of the goals of his
War but he said that pressure was the
key he said uh the more the pressure the
greater the chances now shortly after
that Hamas released its own statement in
which it said that it was willing to
release uh the prisoners if all
Palestinian prisoners were released
relas by
Israel Global News investigative
journalist Dort Bell thanks so much for
your
coverage and rallies were held across
Canada today condemning Israeli air
strikes in Gaza prop Palestinian
demonstrators are demanding an end to
the bombardment and they accused the US
and Canada of looking the other way as
to isra reports events were held in
Canadian cities to bring attention to
the 200 Israelis kidnapped by
Hamas pal
Pro Palestinian protesters marched in
Winnipeg and across the country
expressing anger at the Relentless
Israeli air strikes in
Gaza and helplessness over what comes
next we're really outrage and we're very
very afraid for what's to come because
who knows what Israel will commit in the
dark the rallies were held after
Israel's most intense bombardment yet in
the conflict we're fed up and we know
that we're complicit in this on Friday
the United Nations passed a resolution
calling for a ceasefire Canada was one
of 45 Nations that abstained because the
resolution did not specifically condemn
Hamas for its attack on October 7th that
Israel says killed 1,400 of its
citizens these demonstrators call
Israel's bombardment and blockade
Collective punishment of 2 million
people half of them under 18 find it
just unacceptable that the Canadian
government does not request the
immediate ceasefire prime minister
Justin Trudeau supports a humanitarian
pause to help get Aid into Gaza but he
has stopped short of calling for a
ceasefire people are angry people are
hurt people are worried for their loved
ones that hurt is on display in Canada's
Jewish community in Downtown Montreal
people posted Flyers of some of the 200
Israelis taken cap by Hamas this woman
lost her cousin in the attack I feel
sorry for the children in Gaza but when
I hear in here in Montreal people
justifying the brutality how can you
justify it in Ottawa a vigil was also
organized for the hostages it's been
horrible for the community because
everybody either directly knows somebody
who was murdered injured or taken
hostage or know somebody who knows
somebody an attack and response
that's left many Canadians deeply shaken
teria isri Global News
Ottawa turning to other news now there's
a sense of relief in the United States
in Maine specifically where the man
suspected of killing 18 people has been
found dead after a 3-day man hunt the
news came just hours after police lifted
a stay-at-home order for the normally
quiet community of Leon Jackson prco is
there and he has our coverage
tonight the search for Robert card came
to an end here inside a trailer at a
recycling facility where he used to work
it's not far from where police found his
car after the shooting investigators say
the suspected gunman died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound there was a
couple of firearms found at the scene
when he took his own life I I don't know
the answer to that over days of intense
searching police came to question
whether was in fact still alive based on
a note found in his home leaving behind
Banking and personal information for
loved ones you know if you talk about is
there a motive here right uh I think
clearly um there's a mental health
component to this that history of mental
health problems did not stop card from
purchasing weapons just days before the
massacre investigators say all the
Firearms they've recovered were legally
purchased families of the victims are
still trying to process how this tragedy
could have ever happened can't even go
bowling you can't even go have a drink
at a bar
or enjoy a meal with your family without
fear Bill Young and his 14-year-old son
Aaron were killed in the bowling alley
along with Aaron's youth bowling coach
did nobody see him walking towards the
building what was going through my
brother and my NE exuse mine Joseph
Walker was killed in the sports bar
after he used a butcher knife to
confront the gunman he could have gone
right out the back door he was only 20
ft from the back door he wouldn't have
been possibly even shot at all but I
knew my son wouldn't do that anyways I
knew that was not going to be Joey
Walker adding to the trauma Lewiston and
the surrounding area have been unable to
mourn instead residents spent days under
lockdown while the suspect was on the
loose yeah only now can they come to
terms with what happened when the
Sheltering place was lifted we knew that
we could come out safely and put this
Memorial out get something started to
show our support this weekend the first
public vigils are expected here in
Lewiston and in the nearby town of
Lisbon where the suspect's body was
found while residents say they reliev
The Manhunt is over the death of the
suspect means they may never get full
answers about what motivated the deadly
Rampage far Jackson frco and L Maine
tonight thank you
Jackson crossborder support coming up
how Nova Scotia Community is showing
support for those reeling from the main
mass
killings the mass shooting in Maine this
week struck a nerve in Canada Nova
scotians know all too well what it's
like to experience tragedy like what
happened in Lewiston Global Nationals
New Atlanta correspondent Heidi petk
spoke with those affected by the tragedy
on April in 2020 to see what their
messages were to those
affected for mallerie col pits the news
South of the Border hits hard even from
almost 1,000 kilometers away it is
important for them to know that I am
thinking about them in April 2020 K pitz
survived the Nova Scotia mass shooting
hiding in her ppic home for hours while
a gunman murdered 22 people the thing
about these ordeals is there there's
really no Survival Guide to surviving
Nova scotians like her are now all too
familiar with the toll such a tragedy
can take even years later you know
survivor's guilt is very real free Port
is right here New Yorker turned
maritimer Allison stra couldn't sleep
after hearing the news about Maine with
family living about a half hour from
where the shootings happened I was
watching a a fire department Twitter and
I saw that they were actually calling in
Medevac and LifeLight to bring people to
the Boston in hospital so you knew it
was big at that point her two sisters
and three nieces spent the day
Sheltering in place as police searched
for the suspect the small towns and back
roads of rural Maine so similar she says
to those the Nova Scotia killer passed
through to evade authorities until he
was shot dead by police 13 hours after
his Massacre began I wanted to send to
send a message to all of Maine that you
know this we're all with you because
it's um it's something that you don't
easily recover from the provincial
health authority realizing the ripple
effect here is reminding Nova scotians
to reach out for mental health support
if they need it it's hard not to maybe
maybe other people can process it
differently but it's very difficult for
me not to pause and uh and feel the pain
of that everyone needs support in their
own way through that colitz says
providing support is urgent now and down
the road which for those in Maine will
be long Heidi petrac Global News
Halifax ahead imported tensions Israel's
war with Hamas ignites conflict here at
home in Gaza with more than 200 hostages
still unaccounted for and Palestinian
losses in the thousands continuing to
pile up many Jewish and Muslim Canadians
here are not only grieving but they're
feeling tensions increased
tonight Heather YK West looks at the
rising reports of anti-Semitism and
islamophobia in
Canada a rabbis house egged and tagged
with swastikas in
BC a jewish-owned business surrounded by
protesters in Toronto Canada's Jewish
Community says increasingly it's feeling
under attack it is obvious that
anti-Semitism is still alive and well
Canada's Palestinian Ian Community is
feeling uneasy as well the murder of a
Palestinian American boy in Illinois
this month fresh on everyone's mind the
six-year-old was killed in what police
say was a vicious anti-muslim attack in
Toronto Palestinian parents say their
children are also being targeted since
October 10th our group has been informed
of numerous cases of anti-palestinian
racism discrimination harassment and
bullying in schools across Toronto there
is a lot of disinformation that is out
there sociologist Jasmine Zen worries
that in the wake of the Hamas attack on
Israel islamophobia is now being stoked
in Canada as it was following September
11th that constructed you know Muslims
uh very broadly as being connected to
terrorism and
violence as an example Zen points to the
rallies in support of the Palestinian
people protests that have have been
viewed across communities in very
different ways in Alberta and across the
country of course it's the the vulgar
protests in support of Hamas of course
it's uh anti-semitic because they just
couch their words free Palestine free
Palestine from what we make it clear at
all of our demonstrations that we stand
against all forms of racism including
anti-Semitism I want to stress that
anyone who supports Palestine needs to
understand that uh anti-Semitism is not
what this is about communities seemingly
at odds within Canada sharing a sense of
fear and profound pain Heather urick
West Global News
Calgary next the Palestinian Canadians
who say Ottawa needs to step
[Music]
up as Israel steps up its air and ground
attacks in Gaza the Canadian government
says it's working around the clock to
secure a window for Canadians to exit
the city joining me now is nura whose
mother-in-law uncle and other family
members are stuck in Gaza nura thanks
for joining us and I know you've asked
us not to use your last name at a fear
it could jeopardize your family members
there so let me ask you when was the
last time you were in touch with them
and when was the last time they heard
from the Canadian
government the last time I heard from my
mother-in-law was at 6 o'clock in the
morning yesterday she texted us she said
she was okay and then at 10:00 in the
morning hour time we heard that the cell
towers were bombed and we lost all
communication with 2.3 million people in
Gaza um and so we were immediately
alarmed because we had no idea what was
happening we didn't know anybody that
was reporting on what was happening on
the ground the last time you know we
were also in touch with families
Canadian families who have told us that
the last time the government was in
touch with them was 10 days ago um and
so they have not provided clear plans
they have not created Pathways for them
to evacuate um the Canadian government
was really quick on helping Canadian in
Israel evacuate through chartered planes
why can't they do the same thing why
can't they um you know communicate with
their allies in Israel to create pathway
through Israel for Canadians to leave
through Tel Aviv through Charter PLS
that will protect them Unfortunately
they feel like they have no hope in the
government and are being treated like
second class
citizens you know that the the conflict
and the tension has made its way here
and there's been a lot of misinformation
on both sides so how frustrating has
that been for
you I mean as a Palestinian we are
against any hate being in being um put
on any Community whether it's the Jewish
Community the Muslim Community and the
Christian Community this is not a
religious uh based event a Bas based
um issue and it it it's really dangerous
and really alarming to see the
disinformation going around about these
protesters you know I've heard things
that that are labeling Pro Palestinian
protesters as Hamas supporters and this
is far beyond the truth this is you know
something deplorable like we don't stand
for anything like this we have
Palestinians that have families that are
there that are standing against the war
crimes and the genocide that is
happening you know in real time um in
front of everyone on social media by
independent journalists and so this
blackout that has happened creates a
greater alarm from us because it also
means that they're being blocked from
being able to share what is really
happening on the ground um I mean for
Palestinians here they are fearful to
share to even talk to the news and to
share um anything because of fear of
contribution and this is not the Canada
that we know this is not the Canada that
allows for free freedom of speech and um
you know the the freedom to be able to
protest um and this is It's really
alarming in our community
unfortunately okay Nora I I hope you are
able to somehow get a hold of your
family we're thinking about you take
good
care
thanks that's global national for this
Saturday and we're going to leave you
with more Grim scenes from inside Gaza
as the Israeli military wraps up ramps
up its
operation good
night